comme tous les deux ans aux États-Unis
les Américains sont appelés aux urnes
pour les mythers ce sont des
législatives de mi-mandat qui
interviennent deux ans après l'élection
du président mais pour Joe Biden et le
Parti démocrate ces élections
s'annoncent particulièrement difficiles
alors quels sont les enjeux de ces mi
termes pour l'actuel président réponse
dans factures
[Applaudissements]
lors de ce scrutin plusieurs postes sont
à pourvoir notamment un tiers du Sénat
et chaque siège de la Chambre des
Représentants l'un des deux organes du
pouvoir législatif américain c'est elle
qui détient les cordons de la bourse aux
États-Unis les le budget les dépenses
militaires en l'occurrence en ce moment
qui ont une importance considérable à
cause de l'Ukraine tout ça c'est entre
les mains des représentants le Sénat
le président Biden n'a pas de majorité à
proprement parler il a une majorité
technique dans le sens que il y a 50
voix 50 sièges qui appartiennent au
républicains et 50 aux démocrates sur
100 et c'est donc la vice-présidente
Camara Harris qui fait la différence
pour chaque vote important
historiquement les élections de
mi-mandat sont toujours difficiles pour
le parti présidentiel depuis 1994 elles
ont toutes vu le parti du président en
fonction perdre des sièges à la Chambre
des Représentants seul un président a
fait exception à cette malédiction des
mits c'est George W Bush en 2002 un an
après les attentats du 11 septembre dans
un contexte d'union nationale très fort
aujourd'hui entre l'inflation la
probable récession économique la guerre
en Ukraine avec un risque d'escalade
nucléaire avec la Russie la rivalité
stratégique avec la Chine la situation
inquiète les électeurs les critères de
vote c'est toujours difficile à évaluer
le prix de l'essence à la pompe
traditionnellement on sait qu'aux
États-Unis il y a une espèce de
corrélation entre la cote de popularité
de l'administration en place et le prix
de l'essence à la pompe en ce moment il
est assez élevé et la cote de popularité
du président est assez bas
historiquement parmi les derniers
présidents celui qui a été le plus bas
encore dans les sondages que lui c'est
Donald Trump sont prédécesseurs c'est un
président qui qui traverse une crise
avec multiples plusieurs facettes il y a
une crise économique qui est qui est
grave il y a une inflation qui est très
élevée qui dépasse les 8% depuis le
début de l'année pourtant en juin
dernier les démocrates avaient repris
espoir avec un
[Applaudissements]
mobiliser leurs électeurs autour de ce
thème là il n'est pas certain que ça
suffise à contrebalancer les faits
mobilisateur de l'inflation et de la
crise économique alors concrètement que
risque l'administration Biden pour les
démocrates une défaite serait lourde de
conséquences le parti ne dispose que
d'une très courte majorité à la Chambre
des représentants dans l'hypothèse une
victoire des républicains il pourrait
bloquer le programme de Biden et cela
jusqu'à la fin de son mandat commission
d'enquête comme celle qui a été créée
par la Chambre des représentants pour
enquêter sur les événements du 6 janvier
2021 sera dissoute instantanément à
l'entrée en fonction de la nouvelle
législature s'il est républicains c'est
les républicains ont la majorité les
républicains eux-mêmes commencent à
laisser entendre de façon quasiment
ouverte que ils ont l'intention
eux-mêmes de créer des commissions
d'enquête pour enquêter sur divers
sujets
qui pourraient c'est l'administration
Biden les circonstances du retrait
calamiteux d'Afghanistan en août 2021
par exemple alors une victoire des
républicains à ces élections de mandat
pourraient-elles servir de tremplin à
Donald Trump pour annoncer sa
candidature à la présidentielle 2024
d'abord il faut jamais oublier que les
États-Unis il y a un long processus de
primaire d'élection primaire au sein du
parti donc déjà ça ça commence au
minimum un an avant le scrutin donc vous
n'avez pas intérêt à vous déclarer trop
tôt pour
attirer vers vous toutes les critiques
et vous mettre volontairement sous les
projecteurs Donald Trump a perdu en 2020
il le sait très bien il fait semblant de
l'ignorer mais il le sait
il ne voudra pas rester dans l'histoire
comme un looser et prendre le risque de
perdre une deuxième fois encore une fois
c'est ma théorie mon pari